OUR I AM GOING TO CALL.
THE.
COMMITTEE ON. ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS TO
ORDER.
ONE THANK MY VICE CHAIR FOR
BEING HERE. ARE WHEN OTHER
MEMBERS COME WILL COR FOR A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW WILL START IS
TO SUBCOMMITTEE.
OUT WITH THIS SERGEANT I CAN SEE
RIGHT NOW IS CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SO WELCOME.
WE HEARING AID BILLS TODAY.
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
WILL BE SUBSTITUTING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARE CRISTINA
GARCIA.
AND.
LOOKS LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
IS HERE.
THE BILL THAT PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
WHICH.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY I WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR BUT I SUSPECT
WILL.
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
THAT AND GET A BILL PASSED AND
SIGNED.
SAW AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS ESTABLISH
INSPECTION FREQUENCIES FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES.
GENERATORS AND TRANSPORTERS.
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR.
I HAVE THE OPTION PRESENT A. B.
A TWENTY NINETY FOUR TODAY.
A A BETWEEN NINETY FOUR REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT TALKTALK SUBS
INTRO TO SET A MANDATORY MINIMUM
TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENT
EFFECTIVELY MONITORING AND
ENFORCING.
APPLIANCE AT THE FACILITIES IN
ITS CHARGE.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
EXPRESS CONCERNS REGARDING THAT
REGULATION OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES.
ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES IS THE BAD RECYCLING
PLANT OPERATED BY EXIDE
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE CITY OF BURN
AND. AND SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHICH HAD BEEN ALLOWED TO
GO UNCHECKED FOR OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS DUE TO LAX
PERMITTING. AND ENFORCEMENT.
THE RESPONSE OF THIS AND OTHER
ADVANCED LEGISLATURE INCLUDED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
PUBLIC RESOURCES BUDGET TRAILER
BILL.
A REQUIREMENT THAT DTS HE
ESTABLISHED INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL TO REVIEW AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
IMPROVEMENTS TO DTS SEIZE
PERMITTING. ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC
OUTRAGE AND FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
THE I RP RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE INSPECTION
FREQUENCIES IN STATUTE BASED ON
FACILITY COMPLIANCE HISTORY.
QUALITY OF WAYS TOXICITY RISK
AND PROXIMITY TO SENSITIVE
HABITATS AND POPULATIONS AT RISK
INCLUDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
PACIFIC WITH THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE TSC TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
REQUIRING INSPECTIONS THAT.
PERMITTED A NUMBER ONE PERMITTED
HAZARDOUS WASTE LANDFILL
DISPOSAL FACILITIES AT LEAST
TWICE PER YEAR. IN THE PURSUE
ALL OTHER. PERMITTED HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES AT LEAST ONCE
PER YEAR.
REGULAR MORE FREQUENT SPECTRES
CAN HELP AVOID EXPOSING THE
PUBLIC AND THE ENVIRONMENT A
HARMFUL TOXINS.
AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT VIOLATIONS ARE
DISCOVERED QUICKLY AND
FACILITIES ABOUT BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE.
THEREBY MINIMIZING HARM TO
NEARBY COMMUNITIES.
BOB FINGER WELL IF I COULD
MISTER CHAIR INGRID PROSTRATE
ON.
WELL.
WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE OUR WHAT
IS RIGHT NOW SO I'LL GO AHEAD
HEADED BACK OVER TO THE CHAIR.
BOB.
VERY GOOD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOWER.
.
THE QUAKE SURE.
PERHAPS YOU DO YOU WANT TO
SUMMARIZE WHAT YOUR WITNESS
WOULD HAVE SAID.
.
WELL LET ME. YEAH IF I WOULD
EVEN SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT MAYBE WE CAN HEAR OF
SOME OF THE MEETING OKAY.
.
DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POWERS SPELL.
THAT'S.
TWENTY NINETY FOUR HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES INSPECTION
FREQUENCIES
I.
BUDDY MORENO ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THE THE AN ERICSSON ON BEHALF OF
THE BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS THAT SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY O. ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
VERY GOOD UP DO WE HAVE.
IF THOSE YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DON KEPT KEY WITH MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES HERE TODAY
BEFORE YOU IN OPPOSITION
FORTUNATELY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
C. MTA AND OTHER COALITION LED
BY THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER I AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE CONCERNED AND UNFORTUNATELY
IT MUST OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY
FOUR. AND WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
TIME ESTABLISHING ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS ON DTS SEE WHEN
THEY ARE IN PROCESS OF MOVING
FORWARD A HOST OF DIFFERENT
REFORMS. ARE REGULATORY PACKAGES
AND WHAT HAVE YOU ARE CURRENTLY
FOR THEIR X. CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COST IMPACTS OF THIS WILL HAVE.
ON AN BURDENS HANNAH AGENCY THAT
AGAIN IS SEEKING TO APPROACH FOR
WITH A HOST OF REFORMS.
.
FURTHER I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. ABOUT SO
IN CONJUNCTION WITH DISCUSSIONS
THROUGH THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL AND OTHER FORUMS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOOKING OUT TO ANY
REFORMS TO THE DEPARTMENT AYE IN
A HOLISTIC FASHION. A WE ARE
CERTAINLY AS ON THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY CERTAINLY VERY
INTERESTED IN THAT DISCUSSION
ARM AND HAVE ENDEAVOR TO PUT
FORWARD OUR SUGGESTIONS. RELATED
TO ITEMS THAT WE DO THINK IT
WOULD HELP FURTHER.
COULD HAVE A PROTECT
COMMUNITIES ENSURE WORKABLE
APPROACHES AND ENSURE THAT SELL
OUTS CALIFORNIA WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD IN AN APPROACH THAT DOES
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
MANAGE OUR OWN HAZARDOUS WASTE.
OF VERSES ARE SOLELY SEEKING TO
MOVE OUT OUT OF STATE
HAVE WE ARE CONCERNED AGAIN
ABOUT.
DOT AND FURTHER WOULD NOTE THAT
TIME JUST LAST YEAR AS PART OF A
TWO YEAR COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS.
DGSE ON AND TOOK ON A REVIEW OF
ITS OPERATIONS RELATIVE TO
ENFORCEMENT AND AS PART OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THAT OFFERED TO A
CAME FORTH WITH A HOST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO BOTH
EFFORTS ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS
INSPECTION PROCESS SEES. OTHER
WORKING TOWARDS MOVING SOME OF
THOSE PIECES FORWARD ON
INCLUDING I'M USING A CALLIN
VIRO SCREEN RELATIVE TO
COMMUNITY IMPACTS IDENTIFYING
THOSE. PRIORITIZING INSPECTIONS
AND ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES ARE
THROUGH THE USE OF THAT OUR
TOOL.
AGAIN ULTIMATELY WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THIS
APPROACH ON MAO'S
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED ON ABSENTEE
VERY OF FOCUSED RISK BASED ON
COMPLAINTS HISTORY BASED
APPROACH VERSUS JUST ON SEEKING.
A VERY STRICT NUMBER OF MINIMUM
INSPECTIONS ON MAY NOT BE THE
BEST USE OF RESOURCES MANIA
PROVIDE AND DON INSTITUTE FOR
THE BURDENS. ON THE AGENCY
WITHOUT NECESSARILY HOW THE
CORRESPONDING ARE BENEFICIAL
IMPACTS THE PROTECTION OF THAT I
THINK WORLD LOOKING FORCE
WITHOUT MUCH RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE.
A BIT TOO AGAIN.
AND WISH TO CONVEY OUR INTEREST
IN A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSION ON REFORMS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MORROW BEHALF OF CLEAN HARBORS
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS ITS SUBSIDIARY SAFETY CLEAN
WHICH TOGETHER HAVE.
FOURTEEN UP PERMITTED
FACILITIES.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA A TO KEEP
IT BRIEF THOUGHT MY MY REMARKS I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY ELECT
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE REMARKS.
THAT MISS KEPT HE MADE ON BEHALF
OF HER CLIENTS MAKE IT REAL
QUICKLY IN ADDITIONAL COST YOU'D
STILL QUESTIONS AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT TO IN TERMS OF THE FOCUS IN
TERMS OF PRIORITIES WITH REGARDS
INSPECTIONS. AND AGAIN DEEPER
SHE'S AS AS WAS KEPT HE SAID I
MEAN WE JUST GOT THROUGH FIT WE
COLLECTIVELY.
THE LEGISLATURE A PAID FOR A ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR A
EVALUATION THAT DGSE HAS
RECENTLY. UP CONCLUDED AND HAS
ADOPTED A NUMBER OF UPDATED A
NUMBER OF ITS POLICIES INCLUDING
INSPECTIONS ENFORCEMENT POLICIES
I THINK A BILL LESTER DID TO
HAVE. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF THE.
EDUCATE THAT THE MEMBERS HERE AS
WELL AS A STAKEHOLDERS IN TERMS
OF THAT PROCESS AND WHAT THEY'VE
DONE WITH REGARD TO UPDATING
THEIR POLICIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE EDUCATING THEIR
STAFF. THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE INSPECTIONS
ARE ARE CONSISTENT AND CONDUCTED
IN THE MATTER UPON WHICH WE ALL
EXPECT THANK YOU CURRENT.
THANK YOU ARM WE'RE GOING TO GO
NOW ESTABLISH A FORUM AND THEN
WE'LL GET BACK TO MISTER
CALDERON WHO WHO'S EXPERT
WITNESS HAS ARRIVED.
.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
QUIRK.
HERE CHEN.
I RUMBULA.
BRO.
FRIEDMAN.
REALLY HERE HOLDEN.
WHAT'S WHICH.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
FOR TAKING THE TIME TAPE FEE
OUR SUBSTITUTE DE PINCH HITTER
TODAY.
ALRIGHT.
MISTER CALDERON YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOUR.
EXPERTS.
A THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF WE
HAVE WITH US INTO INGRID ROSTRUM
THE SENIOR ATTORNEY THE CENTER
ON RACE PROPERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK YOU OUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL.
FOR SEVERAL REASONS OF FIRST OF
WHICH.
IS THIS BILL COMES FROM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE I RP THIS
IS OF COURSE A BODY THAT TOOK
TWO YEARS. A LOOKING CLOSELY AT
EVERY AT EVERY PROGRAM AREA ON
AND DEVELOP THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WE'RE VERY
PLEASED THAT THE I RP. DID
INCLUDE RISK BASE FACTORS AS
ENHANCE MY CRITERIA FOR
INSPECTIONS AND REALLY BY
RECOGNIZING THAT OF FACILITIES
THAT ARE LOCATED NEAR EDICT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. A SHOULD BE A
SHOULD HAVE PRACTICES ON THAT OR
MORE PROTECTIVE THAN NOT US SO
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE
ENHANCE PERMITTING CRITERIA FOR
INSPECTION CRITERIA. FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND INCLUDING OTHER
RISK FACTORS AS WELL. I ALSO
WANTED TO MENTION.
IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED IS THAT A D. TSC
OR THIS BILL.
CODIFIES MUCH OF WHAT IS
ALREADY REQUIRED.
OR REQUESTED FROM EPA ON AND.
SO THIS BILL DOESN'T
DRASTICALLY CHANGED THE AMOUNT
OF INSPECTIONS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED BUT DOES SAID IN
STATUTE ARE BECAUSE AS WE KNOW.
I'M DGSE IS AN AGENCY THAT HAS
ON MANY ISSUES.
WITH PROTECTING COMMUNITIES AND
ALSO WITH CONSISTENCE
CONSISTENCY. ACROSS FACILITIES
US SO WE DO WANT TO SEE. THERE
TO BE A A CODIFICATION OF
INSPECTION RECORDS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS A
STANDARDIZED PROCESS ESPECIALLY
SINCE OF PERMITTING DECISIONS
ARE BASED IN PART ON COMPLIANCE
HISTORY. AND LOOKING AT PAST
VIOLATIONS
WITHOUT A CONSISTENT SCHEDULE OF
INSPECTIONS ACROSS ALL THE
FACILITIES ON IT WOULD BE VERY
HARD TO HAVE A FAIR MEASURING
STICK UPON WHICH TO ASSESS
COMPLIANCE HISTORY.
ON I JUST ALSO WANT TO NOTE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INSPECTIONS ON ONE
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
FACILITIES ARE COMPLIANT NIKITA
COMMUNITIES I'M AND IF THEY'RE
NOT COMPLIANT SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THERE IS A SPEEDY. ON
AND FULL A RETURN TO COMPLIANCE
SO THAT WE'RE NOT FACED WITH
SOME OF THE MORE EGREGIOUS
ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WHEN THERE ARE
COMPLAINTS. BUT ISSUES AT THESE
FACILITIES AND THEY'RE NOT
DISCOVERED AT LEAST TWO VERY
REAL IMPACTS AND VERY REAL
ECONOMIC HARM TO THE TO THE
STATE AND OF COURSE REAL A
HEALTH IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES
THAT LIVE NEARBY.
OKAY THANK YOU. FARM.
LET'S SEE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
OR LITTLE GOING A LITTLE OUT OF
ORDER THAT TASK.
THANK YOU CHAIR TOM JACOB ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA.
A OPPOSED FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY.
IS KEPT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M.
BUT SEE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
OF.
OTHER MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE A.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COUNT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ENDS UP I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF.
NOT JUST
BUT FLORA THIS YEAR BUT LAST
YEAR AS WELL A WORK MOVEMENTS
CLOSELY. I'D HAVE A BILL THAT
DID SUCCESSFULLY MAKE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
OUR MY AND HE GOT VERY POSITIVE
LE CLUB CONVERSATION OF
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OPEN THE REAR
END IS THE BELT THAT WEREN'T THE
CASE.
AND I I. FEEL STRONGLY.
THAT THIS BILL AS WELL AS WELL
IN CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER BILLS
ARE ALSO MAKING THEIR WAY.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IS AN IMPORTANT. STEP
THAT WAS HAVING BETTER UP BUT
OVERSIGHT OF THESE FACILITIES
AND AS NOTED A BY.
MY WITNESS HERE TO MY LEFT.
I'M.
IN OF THE THIS IS CODIFYING MUCH
OF WHAT THE EPA REQUIRES AND
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS.
THERE'S BEEN SOME ROLL BACKS.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
OF ENVIRONMENTAL RULES
REGULATIONS SO IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT NEVER THAT BE IS A
STATE ACTUALLY QUALIFY WHAT. IT
IN MANY WAYS HAS BEEN.
THE STANDARD.
IN RECENT YEARS AND FIND WAYS
TO ACTUALLY BEEN STRENGTHENED
OUR ABILITY TO.
AND PROVIDE FOR. SAFE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BURKE PLACES AND
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND AND I'M
GRATEFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF BEING
OPEN TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. AVOCADOS WHETHER
WE GOT THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD OR
NOT THERE'S A LOT TO TALK ABOUT
A LOT TO WORK WITH AND SO I'M
GRATEFUL THAT. OF THAT YOU'VE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION. AND I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
OKAY SO ARE I WILL SAY FIRST
WHILE THE OPPOSITION RACISM
CORRECT CONCERNS DOES THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS.
ARE YOU IS THIS GOING TO BE PART
OF A FULL PACKAGE.
ARE HOW WELL DOES IT FIT.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
AND ARE I HAVE FULL FAITH THAT
THEY WILL.
MAKE SURE THAT IF THIS BILL
DOES GO FORWARD THAT THERE'S
ADEQUATE FUNDING IN THAT IT FITS
INTO THE WHOLE. UP PACKAGE HAD
THEREFORE I WILL RECOMMENDED I
ON THIS AND.
DO BELIEVE THAT.
THEY'LL BE.
MORE EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION
PARTICULAR WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
PART OF. OF THE WHOLE REFORM
PACKAGE AND IS WELL IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS THAT HAS
APPROPRIATE FUNDING SELLERS
RURAL CONCERNS THAT I SHARE WITH
THE. OPPOSITION AND I'M SURE I
SHARE WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL
SO.
ARE AGAIN I GIVE THIS AND I VOTE
AND.
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU LET'S
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS.
I DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
FOR A BI TWENTY NINETY FOUR.
GOOD.
ALRIGHT AND THEN MADAM SECRETARY
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A. B. TWO ZERO NINE FOR
KALRA THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK. AYE QUIRK
AYE CHEN.
CHEN NO ARAMBULA.
PRO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
MATTEUCCI.
MATTEUCCI I.
WILL HOLD ITS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE.
AND NEED FOR ONE MORE VOTE.
BEST OF LUCK TO YOU WELL THANK
YOU SHARE.
OKAY.
A MS RANTS I KNOW YOU WANT TO
GET BACK TO HEALTH COMMITTEE SO
PLEASE COME UP AND.
.
BRING YOUR BALL FORWARD.
SO WE ARE LOOKING ASKED.
A. B..
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE HIGHS
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITY PERMITS
A. B.. TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
REQUIRES AN OWNER OPERATOR FOR
PERMITTED HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITY TO SUBMIT THEIR
APPLICATION FOR RENEWAL TWO
YEARS BEFORE THE PERMIT EXPIRES.
AGAIN THIS WAS A BILL OF THAT
THE GOVERNOR.
LOOKING AT THE FULL OP PICTURE
OF WHAT HE WANT TO DO THAT
RELUCTANCE TO MOVE FORWARD LAST
YEAR.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THAT AS WE LOOK AT THIS IN THE
NEXT YEAR THAT THAT THERE IS
HOPE THAT THIS WILL.
GO THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
AGAIN AND BE SITE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE.
AS YOU'VE INDICATED IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
REQUIRES AN APPLICANT FOR THE
RENEWAL OF A HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITY TO SUBMIT FOR REVIEW AT
LEAST TWO YEARS BEFORE ITS
EXPIRATION. FOR PERMITS EXPIRE
AFTER JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
IN ADDITION THE BILL REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE.
CONTROLLED TO POST ON ITS
WEBSITE.
AND IT'S ESTIMATED TIMELINE OF
KEY MILESTONES IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS.
DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PERMITTING OF ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW'S BROWN UNDER MUCH SCRUTINY
OVER THE YEARS DUE TO A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY. ISSUES WITHIN TERM
PERMITS THAT HAVE LASTED
DECADES.
AND AN INABILITY TO COMPLETE
TASKS
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE PROBLEMS A
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
BUDGET ACT
CREATED AND INDEPENDENT REVIEW
PANEL TO OVERSEE THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERMITTING.
ENFORCEMENT AND FISCAL
MANAGEMENT.
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE PANEL WAS TO REQUIRE PERMIT
APPLICATIONS.
TO REQUIRE PERMIT APPLICANTS TO
SUBMIT THEIR APPLICANT.
INFORMATION ON A TIMELY BASIS
AND THE STAB WISH ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS.
THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES BOTH OF
THESE GOALS BY REQUIRING AN
EARLIER REVIEW OF APPLICATIONS
AS WELL AS ESTABLISHING
DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO BOTH FACILITIES AND OF THE
COMMUNITY BY MANDATING THAT DTS
SEE. POST A TIME LINE OF
ESTIMATED DATES OF KEY
MILESTONES.
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS INGRID ROSTRUM WITH
THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU ARM AND WE ARE AGAIN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL AS
PART OF THE IEP PACKAGE.
AGAIN THIS A ENTITIES ARE
REVIEW PANEL WILL TAKE TOOK A
CLOSE LOOK I'M OVER TWO YEARS ON
AND THIS WAS ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE BELIEVE WOULD HELP PROTECT.
RESIDENTS LIVING NEARBY
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES.
I WILL NOTE THAT DTS SEE HAS.
BEEN CRITICIZED LONG CRITICIZED
FOR THE NUMBER OF EXPIRED
PERMITS.
AT A CERTAIN POINT AND I AM I
DON'T THINK THIS NUMBER HAS
DECREASED THAT MUCH BUT AS MUCH
AS A THIRD OF THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
WERE OPERATING UNEXPIRED
PERMITS.
AND THOUGH THERE HAS BEEN ON
MUCH ATTENTION PLACED ON THIS
ISSUE ARE THERE HAS BEEN LITTLE.
DONE IN THE WAY OF REALLY
ROLLING BACK THIS BACKLOG.
I AM I WILL NOTE THAT
OF THE FACILITY THAT HAS BEEN
OPERATING THE LONGEST ON AN
EXPIRED PERMIT.
HAVE A HAS ITS FIBER TECH IN LOS
ANGELES AND THAT PERMIT EXPIRED
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES AND
THIS GIVES YOU SOME INDICATION
OF ONE ABOUT THE LACK OF
PROGRESS THE DTS HE HAS MADE ON
THIS ISSUE. AND TO JUST THE JUST
THE NUMBER OF YEARS AND IN FACT
IN THISCASE DECADES ARM. A THAT
THESE FACILITIES ARE ARE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE.
ARM.
THE CURRENT LAW IS DESIGNED TO
PROMOTE THIS EXPIRED PERMIT
ISSUE BECAUSE BY DETAILS HIS
ESTIMATION IT TAKES AT LEAST TWO
YEARS TO PROCESS THESE
APPLICATIONS.
SO FOR NOT RECEIVING
APPLICATIONS UNTIL THE PERMIT IS
NEAR EXPIRED BY DESIGN WERE
ALLOWING AND WE'RE PROMOTING IS
A FACILITIES OPTED TO OPERATE ON
THE SIX BY PERMITS AND FINALLY I
WOULD JUST SAY. HAVING CURRENT
PERMITS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE NEAR THESE
FACILITIES BECAUSE IT PROMOTES A
UP TO DATE MITIGATION MEASURES
IT PROMOTES UPTODATE STANDARDS.
ARM AND IT ALLOWS THE DTS HE TO
LOOK AT COMPLIANCE HISTORY AND
VIOLATIONS AS PART OF ITS
PERMITTING DECISIONS SO THESE
DECISIONS NEED TO BE MADE IN A
TIMELY WAY. AND WE SHOULD
THEREFORE.
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE TNC TO MAKE
TIMELY PERMIT DECISIONS THANK
YOU.
VERY GOOD.
ARM.
ARE THERE OTHER IN SUPPORT.
A MORENO ON THE OFFICE HERE
COULD CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
RANDALL FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF
FOUR NAVIENT THREE AIRFORCE
PERMITTED FACILITIES IN SUPPORT
WE WOULD LIKE WE HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH TURNING IN OUR APPLICATIONS
TWO YEARS EARLY WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THE BILL GO FURTHER AND
ACTUALLY.
HAVE A MARK UP FORCING PROCESS
SO WE COULD GET OUR PERMIT
WITHIN THE TWO YEARS WE DON'T
WANT OPERATE WITH EXPIRED
PERMITS EITHERAND AND THAT. I'M.
WITH THAT CONCEPT WE'VE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING BEER MANY
ISSUES INVOLVED. THANK YOU.
ANDREA ENTER WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THE AND ABOUT HIS WITH
CALIFORNIA I'M TO JUSTICE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT AND A
FEELING WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE JUST.
THE RALLY ENVIRONMENT WORKING
GROUP IS ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
PLANKING GETTING THIS AGENCY
IMPORTANT AGENCY UP TO SNUFF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT AN ACCENT ON BEHALF THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL NEXT WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
THE OPPOSITION.
AND.
I HAVEN'T SAID THIS BEFORE BUT
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR MARKS TO
ABOUT FOUR MINUTES MAXIMUM I E.
YOU YOU DID I'M SURE YOU WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AGAIN CHRIS ABOUT THE
HELP OF A CLEAN HARBORS
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
SAFETY CLEAN.
I THINK WE CAN ALL IN THIS ROOM
AGREE THAT THAT.
THE DTS IF WE CAN GET DETAILS
SHE TO PROCESS PERMITS FASTER WE
WOULD ALL BE.
THE BETTER FOR IT I THINK THE
CONCERNS THAT MY CLIENT HAS WITH
REGARDS TO THIS BILL IN THIS AND
THIS A IT WITH ALL THE YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE NO DOUBT ABOUT THE
SINCERITY. OF THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS A PROPONENTS.
A.
REQUIRING REQUIRING A PERMIT
APPLIQUE IT TO SUBMIT A PERMIT
TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE THAT'S ALL
FINE AND WELL.
BUT THE REALITY IS IS THERE'S
NOTHING THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE DTS SEED
TO DO ANYTHING MORE WITH REGARD
TO KEEP TO PROMULGATING THAT
PERMIT AND AS. I REPRESENTING A
CLIENT WHO'S DEALING WITH DTS
SEE WITH A NUMBER OF PERMIT
RENEWALS.
AT THIS POINT AND SOME OF THEM
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON IN BEEN
IN STACEY'S FOR IT FOR MANY
MONTHS NOW.
IT
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT THAT
THE THERE'S THIS EXPECTATION
THAT IF THE APPLICANT SUBMIT
THEIR PERMITS TWO YEARS EARLY
THAT SOMETHING. MAGICAL IS GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THOSE PERMITS ARE
GOING TO BE PROCESS THE QUICKER
MATTER AND AND THEY'RE JUST NOT
AND AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND INCLUDING A AS YOU
KNOW MISTER CHAIR OF A. COST.
COSTS COSTS OF THE PERMIT
ESTIMATES.
THAT'S A HUGE HUGE ISSUE WITH
AND WITH REGARD TO MY CLIENT AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER APPLICANTS
THEY HAVE THEIR PERMIT RENEWALS
AND PROCESS SO. WHY WE WILL
RECOGNIZE?
THE NOTE THAT DESIRE TO SEE.
PERMITS.
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS QUICKER.
I THINK THERE'S IS THERE'S THIS
EXPECTATION THAT THAT THAT THE
LOG JAM IS GOING IS GOING TO
BREAK WITH REGARDS TO BILLS LIKE
THIS AND AND THE REALITY IS IS
EVEN WITH REGARD TO THE I RP
RECOMMENDATION.
THE COMPLETE I OR P.
RECOMMENDATION WITH REGARD TO
THIS PERMITTING. WAS REQUIRED
IDIOCY OBTAIN FULL COST RECOVERY
CONNECTED WITH THIS HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITY PERMIT DECISIONS
THE DTS HE REPORTS THAT THE DTS
HE'S EXISTING.
ARE A.
S..
WELL THAT THAT THE IRE P.
RECOMMENDED THAT THAT THAT THAT
DTS SEE ALSO BE. PUT ON NOTICE
WITH REGARDS TO MOVING THOSE
THOSE PERMITS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT SOME ACTIONS
IT SHOULD TAKE PLACE WITH REGARD
TO EITHER.
APPROVAL OF THE PERIMETER DENIAL
OR BEGINNING OF THE DENIAL OF
THE PRIMITIVE IF THE ACTION
DOESN'T DOESN'T TAKE PLACE SO
AGAIN THIS BILL TAKES CARE OF
ONE SIDE OF THE LEDGER BUT IT
DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE LEDGER WITH REGARDS
TO THE ACTIONS THAT THE.
DEPARTMENT IS TO DO TO
PROMULGATE THOSE PERMITS IN A.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT.
.
STERN VICE CHAIR NO QUESTIONS
ARE.
OTHER MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
THOUGHT HERE WE GO ANOTHER
PERSON AND YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION.
NEITHER AND BOTH.
TOM NINE.
TOM JACOB WITH THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE JUST WHERE TO REGISTER ON
THIS BILL WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
WE'RE NOT SURE THAT IT.
GETS US WHERE WE NEED TO GO FOR
THE REASONS THAT CHRIS OUTLINED.
A ON THE OTHER HAND.
WE DO FEEL IT'S DO IT DEALING
WITH SOME IMPORTANT ISSUES.
A AND. WILL HAVE TO PROCESS IT
FURTHER AS IT MOVES FORWARD BUT.
I JUST WANTED TO REGISTER THAT.
OKAY GIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD ALSO WELL LET'S HEAR
FROM THE OTHER MEMBERS DOES
ANYONE HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT.
ALRIGHT ARM.
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF FRANCE.
AT.
MY MYERS WE GET A MOTION NOW
WOULD SOMEONE LIKE TO MAKE
MOTION.
OKAY
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS IS JUST ONE
STEP.
CLEARLY WERE TRYING TO TAKE CARE
OF A MUCH LARGER PROBLEM BUT I
THINK IF THE SMALL STEPS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I THINK THE.
THE CLARITY THAT'S BEING OFFERED
IN THE BILL AS WELL AS TIME
LINES THERE ISN'T A PERFECT
SOLUTION AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE'RE THERE'RE TEMPS ON BOTH
SIDES TO TRY TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT
FOR THE COMMUNITY. BUT I THINK
IF WE DON'T TAKE.
SMALL STEPS WILL NEVER GET TO
THAT POINT.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OKAY AGAIN.
THE GOVERNOR IS.
I'M VERY CONCERNED THAT. WE DO
SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THE CONCERN IF FIVE
DOESN'T HELP TO HAVE THE.
.
HAVE A TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE OF
IT THEN TAKES TEN YEARS TO.
TO CERTIFY OR TWENTY.
BOB THAT'S SOMETHING WE ALL WANT
TO AVOID. IT IS MY.
OPINION IN TALKING WITH BARBARA
LEAD THE NEW HEAD OF THE A THE
DTS SEE. AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT
THIS IS A DEDICATED GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT SIMPLY DOESN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
SO A LARGE PART OF.
MOVING US FORWARD AND ALL OF US
WANT DECISIONS FASTER WHETHER
YOU'RE FOR OR AGAINST THE
FACILITY.
AND A LARGE PART OF THAT HAS TO
COME THROUGH THE BUDGET.
SO I'M HOPING THAT WE WILL SEE
CHANGE IN THE BUDGET IN THE MAY
REVISE.
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID I'M SURE
THAT.
YOU'RE WORKING WITH GOVERNORS
OFFICE AND WE WILL LOVE.
BRING THIS FORWARD AGAIN IF WE
CAN COMBINE THIS WITH MORE
RESOURCES SO THAT THE BILL SO
THAT.
THE JOB.
DECISIONS CAN BE MADE IN A MORE
TIMELY MATTER IT WOULD MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE.
SO OP WITHOUT HAVING AYE
RECOMMENDATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AB TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
ANDREAS THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I WROTE.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I
WHAT'S A CHIEF RIGHT TO CHEAT BY
SELECT SIX.
ALRIGHT BILL PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS ARM WE HAVE ALL
OF OUR.
MEMBERS WELL WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS HERE THAT I'D LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL ON MISTER CALORIES
DEL.
THAT WE CAN.
.
GET THAT DEATH THROUGH.
WE NEEDED ONE MORE VOTE ON NOT
A. B. ARCTIC KAURA.
TWENTY NINETY FOUR HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES. INSPECTION.
MAKING THE INSPECTIONS HAPPENED
A MORE REGULAR BASIS.
OUR MADAM SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINETY
FOUR KALRA.
OUR NUMBER ONE.
BRO.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN ICE WOULD YOU HAVE FOR.
OKAY WE HAVE FOUR VOTES AND
WE'LL LET YOU CHECK IN AGAIN
WITH MR PEROT AND MR ARAMBULA
LATER.
I NEXT I'D LIKE TO DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THEIR THREE
BILLS PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
THEY'RE ALL COMMITTEE BILLS
WHICH I HAVE I BELIEVE ALL OF US
HAVE.
SIGNED ON TO.
AB TWENTY NINE HUNDRED.
A PROPOSED NEW PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM PRELIMINARY TECHNICAL
REPORT.
AB TWENTY NINE A ONE CLEANING
CLEANING PRODUCTS RIGHT TO KNOW
ACT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
REVISIONS.
ARE AND AB TWENTY NINE OH TO.
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
BOB MAY I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALRIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WE HAVE AND AB TWO NINE ZERO
ZERO COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS AND
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSENT.
AB TWO NINE ZERO ONE A COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS DO PASSED A
FLOOR CONSENT. AND AB TWO NINE
ZERO TWO COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS DO PASSES AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSENT.
QUIRK.
I QUIRK I
CHEN.
CHEN AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA BY
WROTE.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I WENT SEARCHING
RHETORIC.
TARGET.
THE NEXT THREE BELLS ARE MINE.
CHAU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU I'M GONNA BE TAKING
THESE IN NUMERICAL ORDER SO I
HOPE YOU'RE ALL SITTING HALF.
SO AB NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND A.
TWENTY SEVENTY TWO AND THEN AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY.
ALRIGHT.
CHAU. MAYBE NINETEEN EIGHTY
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS.
.
SO FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY EXTENDS THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
COMMENCING CIVIL ENFORCEMENT.
FOR ABOVE GROUND PETROLEUM
STORAGE ACTOR A P. S. A..
VIOLATIONS FROM ONE TO FIVE
YEARS.
SPILLS FROM PETROLEUM TANKS
COURSE CAN LEAD TO A HOST OF
PROBLEMS FROM CONTAMINATED SOIL
AND DRINKING WATER. TO INCREASE
FIRE RISK.
A PSA WAS ENACTED NINETEEN
NINETY AS DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
SPELL OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLONS OF.
PETROLEUM FROM AN ABOVE GROUND
PETROLEUM TANKS.
IN.
INTO SENSITIVE MARSHES AND THE
BAY DELTA ESTUARY.
ONE YEAR STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
CURRENT LIMIT.
SO WE WANT TO INCREASE THIS TO
FIVE AND SO THE QUESTION IS WHY.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT USUALLY
TAKES AT LEAST A YEAR AND
SOMETIMES MORE.
EMPLEADOS TO GAY ASIANS
INVOLVING
OF VIOLATIONS OF A PSA.
THESE YOU'RE COMPLEX
INVESTIGATIONS THAT OFTEN
INVOLVE VIOLATIONS OF MULTIPLE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO GET THESE
THINGS RIGHT.
A PSA IS ENFORCED BY THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCIES ALSO CALLED COOPER'S.
OUR THE COOPERS UNIFY VIETMINH
ASTRAY XIN PERMIT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL LOSS.
OF THE LAWS THAT COOPER IS IN
FORCE EIGHT PSAS HE ONLY WON
WITH ONE YEAR STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS.
SO YOU HAVE AN UNDERGROUND TANK.
OR ANY OTHER SITUATION YOU HAVE
A FIVE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
I HAVE KEVIN WONG HERE FROM THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND JUSTICE MILAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NOT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FIRE
MENTAL. HEALTH ADMINISTERS
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
.
LET'S SEE LET'S START WITH MR
Y..
THAT.
.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
KEVIN LONG AND THE DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
APPEARING.
ON BEHALF OF NANCY O'MALLEY.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO EXTEND THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
FOR CIVIL ACTIONS
BROUGHT UNDER THE ABOVE GROUND
PETROLEUM STORAGE ACTFROM ONE
YEAR. TO FIVE YEARS.
.
BY DOING SO BY EXTENDING THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS.
IT'LL MAKE BEST OF OUR MENTAL
LAW CONSISTENT WITH OTHER AREAS
OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
AND ALSO REFLECT THE REALITIES
OF THESE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS.
.
THE IMPORTANCE OF NAPSTER AND
ENFORCEMENT OF NAPSTER.
DESERTED IN AT STATED.
.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT.
JESS IS IMPORTANT
AS THE OTHER AREAS.
OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAW LIKE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
HAZARDOUS WASTE LAW.
HAS MATERIALIZE.
AND ALL OF THOSE AREAS OF LAW.
GET THE FIVE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
IN ORDER TO BRING CONSISTENCY.
I'D THE ABOVE GROUND PATROLLING
STORAGE ACT SHOULD ALSO HAVE
THAT FIVE YEAR STATUTE
LIMITATIONS.
NOW BEYOND CONSISTENCY.
.
EXTENDING THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS
BUT ALSO REFLECT THE REALITIES
OF THESE TYPES OF INVESTIGATIONS
AND HOW THEY COME TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES.
THE ONLY WAY THESE CASES COME TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES.
IS WHEN THEY REFERRED BY LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATORS
THE COOPERS.
THE COOP IS DO THEIR INSPECTIONS
THEY OBSERVE VIOLATIONS.
AND NAY USE THAT TAKE THE TIME
TO USE THEIR OWN ADMINISTRATIVE
ENFORCEMENT.
STEPS.
TO BRING IT FACILITY BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE.
IT'S ONLY AFTER THEY TAKE THAT
TIME TO EXHAUST ALL OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STEPS.
IF THEY REFER THEM TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
SO WHAT IT COMES OVER TO THE
IT'S ALREADY DELAYED.
AS FAR AS SCHEDULED.
THEM WHEN WE GET THE CASE
OUR OFFICES AT THE INVESTIGATE.
FURTHER
WE LOOK INTO OTHER AREAS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW THAT ONLY
ABSOLUTE ELATION BUT.
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
VIOLATIONS.
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL LAW
HAS ITS MATERIAL VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE WE WANNA.
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
THESE CASES.
AND ONE YEARS IS IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO DO THESE TYPES OF
CASES.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
.
WE'D ASK THAT.
STAND THE SATCHEL LIMITATIONS
THE FIVE YEARS
AND WE WATCHED IT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IBOOK. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS JUST ALONG
THE HOPE FOR THE COOPER IS.
I WANT TO YOU MUCH TIME TO
RANDY WHO IS. A COOP IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY BUT WE JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE A FORMA COMMENTS.
BASICALLY IT AS WELL AS
MENTIONED BEFORE THERE'S THERE'S
ACTUALLY SIX DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
UNDER THE CERTIFY UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENTS HERE IN A COOPER
IS NAY ALL. HAVE BAD STATURE
LIMITATIONS THERE FIVE YEARS
THIS TO BE CONSISTENT.
BUT DUE TO DO ENFORCEMENT
SOMETIMES WE ALSO WORK WHETHER
AGENCIES TO LOOK AND AND HELP US
INVESTIGATE. AND JUST IT TAKES
TIME AND.
WITH RESOURCES AND GETTING
EVERYTHING SET UP IT COULD TAKE
IT TAKES IN NUMBER MONTHS IF NOT
A YEAR TO. DO A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A SAY NO WITNESSES DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CENA WITNESSES SO OPEN UP THE
QUESTIONS THAT REMEMBERS.
THIS HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE CHAIR AND
WITH THAT SAID MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE COLD ROLLED.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY QUIRK.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
CHEN.
CHEN I.
ARAMBULA.
WROTE.
WROTE NOT VOTING.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MATTEUCCI MERETZ WHICH YOU.
FOR.
THANK YOU.
.
UP NEXT I'LL DEAL WITH.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY TWO
CONTAMINATES OF EMERGING CONCERN
.
UP JOB MISTER VICE CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY TWO WILL
CREATED DEDICATED PROGRAM AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
TO RESEARCH MONITOR AND
UNDERSTAND CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN OR.
SOMETIMES CALLED C. E. SEES.
AND OUR WATER SOURCES AND THEIR
IMPACT ON HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE INTENT IS TO HAVE DECISIONS
MADE ABOUT REGULATING WATER
QUALITY ON ROBUST SCIENCE.
NOT MAJORITY VOTES TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
.
AGAIN EVEN I AS A SCIENTIST
DON'T WISH TO BE AN AUTHORITY IN
THIS AREA WE REALLY WANT THE
SCIENCE DONE BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO IT. AND HAVE THE
TIME.
NOW THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF CHEMICALS IN COMMERCE TODAY
THE CONSUMERS USE IN AND AROUND
THEIR HOMES.
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE
RELEASED INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY ONLY A HANDFUL OF
THE CHEMICALS ENTERING OUR WATER
HAVE NUMERIC WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS IN WHICH THE STATE
CAN.
REGULATE FOR WHICH OUR PUBLIC US
WATER SYSTEMS
SHOULD MONITOR.
CONSTITUENTS EMERGING CONCERN
REPRESENTS A CHALLENGING PROBLEM
FOR REGULATORS TO ADDRESS.
OWING TO LIMITED SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THEIR SOURCES
FATES IN THE FAX.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY TWO WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE WATER BOARD
THE EXTENT FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE.
TO MAKE RESEARCH ON.
CONSTITUENTS STATUETTES PERMIT
AT.
WHICH WILL ENABLE THE STATE TO
GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE ON
POTENTIAL WATER CONTAMINANTS AND
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE.
SOME POLISH QUESTIONS IT BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF WHAT THE CONSTITUENTS MIGHT
INCLUDE.
OF THE NEXT STEP AFTER.
IDENTIFICATION IN.
IS.
.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE M. PACKED
ON M. ON FUTURE REGULATIONS IN
COORDINATION WITH THE EXISTING.
SCIENCE ADVISORY.
.
PANELS.
BROUGHT MY STAFF AND ARE WILLING
AND HAPPY TO WORK WITH STATE
HOLES ON CLARIFYING THESE POLICY
QUESTIONS.
WITH ME TODAY IS.
ADRIA VENTURA FROM CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND BOB.
.
BOCOCK
WITH THE AARON.
BROCKOVICH FOUNDATION.
OF WHICH WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST.
AT AT ALL RIGHT ANDREA PLEASE GO
AHEAD AYE ANDREA VENTURE WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION.
AND I SPEND A LOT OF MY CAREER
WORKING ON DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS AS WELL AS.
CONTAMINANTS OF EMERGING
CONCERN. AND I'LL JUST MAKE TWO
POINTS ARE VERY QUICKLY WE DO
BELIEVE THIS IS THE DIRECTION WE
NEED TO GO AND THE REALITY IS
THESE CHEMICALS ARE OUT THERE.
WE NEED TO GET A GRASP ON THAT
IN ORDER TO PROTECT
A CALIFORNIA'S DRINKING WATER.
UP THAT SAID I ALSO WOULD. OF
MAKE MENTION THAT THE MORE DATA
WE HAVE THE BETTER AND EVEN MORE
COST EFFECTIVE DECISIONS WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE DOWN
THE ROAD IN PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC.
THAT MEANS MAY BE POLLUTION
PREVENTION BY UNDERSTANDING THE
SOURCES THAT MEANS REALLY HAVE A
GOOD UNDERSTAND WHAT TREATMENT
REALLY IS NECESSARY. ARM AND SO
WE DON'T OVER DO IT BUT WE ARE
PROTECTIVE.
I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS ONE OTHER
ISSUE I HAVE HEARD IN THE
BUILDING THAT THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT PUSHED BACK BECAUSE THE
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM. HAS.
SOME INTEREST IN ALREADY
LOOKING AT ATTACHMENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN KEEP IN MIND
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RECYCLED WATER FOR POTABLE
REVIEWS. WE ARE LOOKING AT WASTE
WATER THAT IS ONLY ONE SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION IN OUR WATER. A
STORM WATER PRODUCTS ENDING UP
IN OUR WATER AND LEACHING
CHEMICALS ARE ALSO PROBLEMS AND
I WOULD ARGUE THAT PERHAPS THE
CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE CONCENTRATIONS MAY
DIFFER DEPENDING ON THE SOURCE
OF THIS MOVES US TOWARD
ADDRESSING THAT DATA GAP AND
THAT'S WHY CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND OUR MEMBERS SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
KAREN A.
NO BOB CHAIRMAN BOCA OF YEAH
AARON.
BROCKOVICH FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BOB
OKAKURA BROCKOVICH FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
UNIT DRINKING WATER AND AND.
CLEAN WATER.
DISCHARGE STANDARDS IN THE
STATE CALIFORNIA GOAT DECADES.
WITHOUT REGULATION.
EVERYONE'S FAMILIAR WITH THE
THE QUOTE ERIN BROCKOVICH
CHEMICAL HEXAVALENT CHROMIUM WE
PASSED FOUR PIECES OF
LEGISLATION.
IN THIS VERY ROOM ADDRESSING
THAT THAT VERY CHEMICAL AND YET
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A MAXIMUM
CONTAMINANT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST CALIFORNIA
LAW.
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS NOT
ONLY FOR THE CHEMICALS THAT. ARE
COMMERCE PUTS INTO REGULATION
BUT YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE CHEMICALS BREAKDOWN IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OFTENTIMES THE
DAUGHTER CHEMICALS ARE ACTUALLY
MORE TOXIC THAN THE CHEMICALS
THEMSELVES. ON IN OUR TREATMENT
PLANT PROCESSES WHETHER IT'S
WASTE WATER OR INNER SURFACE
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS WE
OXIDIZERS CHEMICALS EITHER USING
OZONE UV CHLORINE CHLORINE
DIOXIDE. AND THOSE PROCESSES
THEMSELVES MAKE A MYRIAD OF
OTHER CHEMICALS THAT ARE
OFTENTIMES MORE TOXIC AND WE
HAVE A TENDENCY NOT TO STUDY
THOSE. WHEN TREATING THE WATER
IN THE BALLPARK ABA UNIT
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN'S AREA.
WE WERE WE WERE FACED WITH T.
C. E. AND THEN IT'S BREAKDOWN
CHEMICALS WE GOT TEN YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD AND WE WERE HIT WITH.
UP AMMONIUM PER CHLORATE FIVE
YEARS LATER WE WERE HIT WITH%
NDMA. THESE CHEMICALS DON'T HAVE
REGULATIONS TODAY THEY ARE
CHEMICALS OF EMERGING CONCERN
AND THEY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE THEY TAKE TIME FOR THE
PUBLIC TO. ACTUALLY PUT
TREATMENT BARRIERS IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER WEST I'M THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF WATER REDUCE
CALIFORNIA BOMB WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
WERE STILL REVIEWING IT.
WE PLAN TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THIS AUTHOR AND WERE
GENERALLY SUPPORT ABOUT THE
APPROACH HE'S TAKING.
CURRENTLY I JUST WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT THROUGH THAT WATER
BOARDS RECYCLED WATER POLICY FOR
RECYCLED WATER THEY MUST REVIEW
CFCS.
AND DO OUR MONITORING REVIEW
THE MONITORING REQUIREMENTS FOR
RECYCLED WATER EVERY FIVE YEARS
AND THEN FACT THAT REVIEW HAS
JUST HAPPEN IN FACT LAST MONTH
AN EXPERT PANEL DID PUT OUT A
REPORT. A ON CALLED MONITORING
STRATEGIES FOR CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN FOR RECYCLED
WATER.
AMONG THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
REPORT.
OUTLINED UPDATING A RISK BASED
FRAMEWORK FOR MONITORING CECE'S
FOR HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
UPDATING THE FRAMEWORK AND AND
WITH THE GENERAL APPROACH OF
THAT EXPERT PANEL AGAIN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS BILL AND WE'RE
GOING TO REVIEW IT ON HOW IT
ALIGNS WITH THAT PROCESSES THAT
ARE GOING ON AT THE WATER BOARD.
AND ON GENERALLY SUPPORT ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MULLIN BEHOF
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTIVES WE HAVE A MULTITUDE
OF RESPONSIBILITIES RANGING TWO
WATER WASTE WATER DRINKING WATER
TETRA. SO WE DO LIKE THIS MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH WE DON'T JUST
HAVE THAT RECYCLED WATER FOCUS.
EMERGING A CHEMICALS EMERGING
CONCERNED AFFECT EVERY ASPECT OF
WATER SO WE DO LIKE THIS
APPROACH ENERGI VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JUST GO
GAGA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION AGENCY
IS. A WE APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THIS AND BILL TO TAKE A
SCIENTIFIC APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THESES AND WATER
SOURCES SO FOR THAT REASON WE
TOOK A SUPPORTING CONCEPT
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND STAFF AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
BILL ELLIOTT ENVIRONMENT WORKING
GROUP WE SUPPORT THIS INNOVATIVE
APPROACH THANK YOU.
IF ENACTED ON BEHALF THE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
A MARINE ON THE OFFICE YOUR CLIP
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ALL OPENED UP TO.
PLEASE MOMENTOUS.
I'M SORRY ONCE AGAIN.
NEITHER OPPOSED HER.
SUPPORT BUT.
TOM JACOB ON BEHALF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA.
INITIALLY HAD SOME.
SOME SIGNIFICANT MISGIVINGS
ABOUT.
THIS.
SAT DOWN WITH STAFF LAST WEEK
LATE LAST WEEK TO DISCUSS THE
AMENDED VERSION.
M..
SATISFIED THAT THIS IS INDEED
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND APPRECIATE THE.
.
THE CHAIRS INITIAL COMMENTS IN
HIS INITIAL STATEMENT.
A ABOUT HIS INTENT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME ADDITIONAL.
MODIFICATIONS TO THE BILL. NON
AND WILL BE RECOMMENDING THAT
OUR FOLKS A CONSIDERABLE SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DEUS THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING
THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR WAS LIKE CLOSE.
AS I WILL CERTAINLY BE WORKING
AS A SAID WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS LE CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL.
.
A SEWER AGENCIES ARE AS WELL AS
RECYCLED WATER.
I.
AGAIN THE INTENT HERE IS
LET'S DECIDE BY SCIENCE.
ARE WERE ENVISIONING AS WE TALK
TO THE WATER BOARD SOMETHING
LIKE TWO TO THREE PEOPLE. WHO
ARE DEDICATED TO THIS AND
PERHAPS THEY CAN EVEN COME UP
WITH THE STANDARD FOR CHROME
SIX?
I REALLY HOPED.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B..
TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO QUIRK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
I QUIRK I.
CHEN.
CHEN I.
I DON'T BELONG.
BROKE.
BRO BY.
FRIEDMAN.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WHAT AT SEARCHING MERETZ RICHIE
I?
FIVE.
OKAY.
MY LAST BILL.
A. B. TWENTY SIX SIXTY.
ARE DEALING WITH RETAIL WASTE.
SO. THANK.
NOW WE HAVE A VERY GOOD CREW
HERE.
SO FIRST OF ALL.
.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ODDS NICE TO NICE TO BE HERE
TODAY AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY ALLOWS
A RETAILER.
WITHOUT HAVING TO MAKE A WEST
WASTE DETERMINATION TO SHIP A
SURPLUS HOUSEHOLD.
ZOOMER PRODUCT TO REVERSE
DISTRIBUTOR.
WHAT WE'RE FINDING NOW IS WHEN
THESE
DECISIONS HAVE TO BE MADE AT THE
RETAIL LEVEL?
THAT THERE IS A THE EXPERTISE
THERE.
AND THERE IS THE EXPERTISE AT
THE REVERSE DISTRIBUTOR A
REVERSE DISTRIBUTOR FOR THOSE
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THAT TERM
BEFORE. IS SOMEBODY WHO TAKES IN
THE MATERIALS FROM THE RETAILER.
AND THEN DETERMINES CAN THEY BE
REUSED CAN THEY BE GIVEN AWAY OR
ARE THEY SOME SORT OF WASTE AND
HOW WHAT KIND OF WASTE.
HAZARDOUS OR.
CAN IT GOING TO LANDFILLS AND
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT THE DECISION
THAT IN THE RETAIL AND THEY HAVE
THE EXPERTISE FOR AND THAT'S THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR THE BILL.
.
BR I'M.
SHOW DUE TO THE UNCERTAINTY WITH
IN THE RETAIL INDUSTRY AS TO
WHEN A PRODUCT BECOMES A WASTE.
OF RETAILERS AND MANUFACTURERS
HAVE DECIDED TO AVOID THE RISK
OF ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
BY ESTABLISHING VERY
CONSERVATIVE WASTE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES
SO THEY WILL OFTEN THROW THINGS
OUT OR DECLARE THEM HAVE REDUCE
WASTE WHEN THEY'RE ACTUALLY
EITHER REUSABLE OR THEY'RE NOT
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
.
THE RESULT IS THAT PRODUCTS
COULD OTHER BUYS THE DONATOR
SALVAGED OR NOT.
SO THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEM WHEN THAT IS FAKE VEXED
STOCKHOLDERS.
SHE'S BEEN STAKEHOLDERS FOR
YEARS.
WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE.
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION I DO WATCH
RECOGNIZE WE'RE WORKING WITH A
VARIETY OF STAKE HOLDERS TAKING
THEIR INPUT IN ORDER TO MAKE
THIS A BETTER AND SAFER PROCESS.
OUR THIS BILL IS THE RESULT OF
MANY STAKEHOLDERS WORKING
TOGETHER AND COMING UP WITH THIS
HOT NEW PROCEDURE. WHICH I
GENUINELY THINK WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA.
A.
HOW CAN I SAY MORE CONSERVATIVE
PLACE IN TERMS OF THE WAY THAT
IT USES ITS MATERIALS? NOT
DESIGNATING THINGS IS HAZARDOUS
WHICH ARE NOT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
OH YES WITNESSES.
I DON'T HAVE A LIST JUST
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS SHERRY RUDOLPH
I'M CHIEF MARKETING OFFICER OF A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT CALLED GET
THREE SIXTY. GOOD THREE SIXTY IS
A GLOBAL LEADER IN PRODUCT
PHILANTHROPY AND PURPOSEFUL
GIVING AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT WE WORK WITH CORPORATIONS
THAT HAVE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
PRODUCT TO DONATE. AND WE MATCH
UP THOSE DONATIONS WITH
NONPROFITS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHO NEED THESE I'D NEED THOSE
ITEMS IN ORDER TO DELIVER ON
THEIR OWN LOCAL MISSIONS AND
MANDATES WE'VE BEEN IN OPERATION
FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS. WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN NINE
BILLION DOLLARS AND CRITICALLY
NEEDED GOODS TO PEOPLE IN NEED
INCLUDING CHILDREN FAMILIES THE
HOMELESS VETERANS SURVIVORS OF
DISASTER AND MANY MORE.
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND NONPROFITS WHO
ARE MEMBERS OF GET THREE SIXTY
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING MORE THAN THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE FOUND THAT
THERE'S A REALLY SIGNIFICANT
VALUE IN A STRONG DONATION
ECOSYSTEM. SO WE HELP
CORPORATIONS RESOLVE THE
BUSINESS CHALLENGE OF
RESPONSIBLY DONATING ACCESS
GOODS FOR MAXIMUM IMPACT WE ALSO
HELP NONPROFITS ACCESS GOODS
THAT HELP THEM DELIVER ON THEIR
MISSIONS. THAT THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO OTHERWISE
DONATIONS ALLOW NON PROPOSITION
WRETCH THEIR BUDGETS EVEN
FURTHER ALLOWING THEM TO FOCUS
MORE ON THEIR SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS AS OPPOSED TO THE
PURCHASE OF GOODS.
THROUGH THESE NONPROFITS
INDIVIDUALS FACING CHALLENGING
LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES GET THE GOODS
THAT THEY NEED TO LIVE DAY TO
DAY. AND GOODS ARE GIVEN A NEW
LIFE NOT ONLY REDUCING WASTE BUT
KEEPING THEM OUT OF LANDFILLS
AND ALSO ALLOWING US TO
COLLECTIVELY BUILD MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES FOR THE
FUTURE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DISTRIBUTE MORE
NEEDED PRODUCT WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
THE DEMANDS BUT WE CAN'T FULFILL
THAT DEMAND BECAUSE OF CURRENT
RESTRICTIONS.
MANY OF OUR CORPORATE PARTNERS
WILL NOT ALLOW THEIR DONATED
PRODUCTS TO BE DISTRIBUTED IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY BECAUSE THE
CURRENT SCRUTINY AROUND
HAZARDOUS WASTE POSES TO HIGHER
RISK.
THREATS TO THE MOVEMENT AND
DISTRIBUTION OF CERTAIN KINDS OF
DONATIONS CAN THREATEN AND
DISRUPT THE MOVEMENT OF ALL
DONATIONS SINCE RETAILERS CANNOT
RUN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS EACH CATERING TO A
SPECIFIC TYPE OR CATEGORY OF
CONSUMER PRODUCT.
OUR NONPROFIT MEMBERS CONSTANTLY
ASK FOR ITEMS LIKE PERSONAL CARE
GOODS SHAMPOO COSMETICS AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES. BECAUSE THESE
ARE HIGH NEED GOODS AND THEY
ALWAYS NEED TO BE REPLENISHED
THE THAT THESE ITEMS HAVE VALUE
IN THESE NONPROFITS ARE OFTEN
WILLING TO PAY FOR SHIPPING. OR
EVEN PICK UP THOSE ITEMS
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THE ITEMS ARE
IN SUCH HIGH NEED.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE IT'S THREE
SIXTEEN SURE THAT DONATIONS ARE
HANDLED RESPONSIBLY THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE DISTRIBUTION CHAIN.
ARE MEMBERS ARE NONPROFIT
MEMBERS GO THROUGH AN EXTENSIVE
VETTING PROCESS WITH US TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT ONLY
VERIFIED FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
ORGANIZATION. BUT ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT DONATED PRODUCTS ARE
DISTRIBUTED AND USED
APPROPRIATELY AND AS INTENDED.
WELL WE'D LIKE TO SEE SAM
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE CHANGES
WITHIN THE BILL CURRENTLY THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN WE DO SUPPORT
THE OVERALL GOAL AND THE CONCEPT
OF THE BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO BRING
MORE CRITICALLY NEEDED GOODS.
HERE TO CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE NICOLE
CAN UNITS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS
MANUFACTURE A VARIETY OF
CONSUMER GOODS AND THEY'RE SOLD
OUT OF RIGHT YOU RETAILERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I THE
FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK STATE
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT.
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE FINDING THAT
RETAILERS ARE VERY
CONSERVATIVELY MANAGING OUR
UNSOLD PRODUCTS WHICH IS LEADING
TO UNNECESSARY WASTE.
AS A RESULT THROUGH THIS BILL
WE ARE HOPING.
TO REDUCE THAT NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS THAT ARE SENATE
UNNECESSARILY TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
I IN MOST INSTANCES WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE STILL VALUE
IN THESE PRODUCTS AND TO DISPOSE
OF.
THESE ITEMS WITHOUT GIVING THEM
THE CHANCE FOR LIQUIDATION
DONATION RECYCLING SUCH A.
IT'S EXPENSIVE FOR
MANUFACTURERS EXPENSIVE FOR
RETAILERS BUT YOU MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WE HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL
MAKE IT CLEAR FOR RETAILERS AND
MANUFACTURERS WHEN THE REVERSE
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS.
IT CAN BE USED AND WILL ALLOW
FOR CONSOLIDATION OF THOSE
PRODUCTS PRODUCTS TO OPEN UP
MORE MARKETPLACES.
I'M AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO FINE TUNE THE LANGUAGE I'M
AND WE REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
SAYS THE.
BASS SOLUTION THAT CAME OUT OF
THE RETAIL HAZARDOUS WASTE WORK
GROUP THAT WE ALL PARTICIPATED
AND FOR.
A YEAR ALL OVER ALTERING AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I'M AND WE DID
DEVELOP A REPORT THAT WAS.
DELIVER TO THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ONE OF THE
OPTIONS IN THE REPORT WE BELIEVE
I'M ITS WENT BUST OPTIONS THANK
YOU.
DURING.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MALONE FOR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS WE ACTUALLY HAVE ALL
THREE PROGRAMS WE HAVE THE
COOPER PROGRAM WE HAVE THE
MEDICAL WASTE PROGRAM AND THE
SOLID WASTE PROGRAM. AND YES
INDEED IT HAS BEEN A VEXING
PROBLEM NOT ONLY DO WE SOMETIMES
OVER CHARACTERIZE THE WAYS WE DO
SOMETIMES UNDER CHARACTER.
SO WE DO BELIEVE THIS WILL HELP.
DO THE CHARACTERIZATION OF THAT
WASTE MORE ACCURATELY BETTER IN
THESE CONSOLIDATED AREAS THAT
RELY ON THESE THOUSANDS OF
RETAIL STORES TO DO THAT WASTE
CHARACTERIZATION STATES ONE STEP
IN AN IMPORTANT PROGRESS. AND
DEATH THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
POOL INTRODUCING THE BILL.
OF THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAWN KEPT KEY MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR JIM WOOD OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WERE NOT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL. A
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT ONE ASPECT IN THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ADD. A NEW
EXEMPTION TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE.
LANGUAGE THAT DOES PROTECT TO
LET.
INFORMATION FROM.
DISCLOSURE TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IS AS NARROW AS POSSIBLE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR.
THE COMMITTEE IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS TOWARD THAT END
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT ITSELF BEYOND IT WE DO
SUPPORT GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
THANKS.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
RALPH'S IN SUPPORT.
AMARILLO MAP OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TRANSMETA BEHALF OF RITE AID AND
SUPPORT.
ANDREA ENTER WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION.
AYE YOU OUGHT TO IS PART OF THE
RETAIL WASTE.
WORKGROUP AND WHILE WE ARE NOT
IN THE POSITION AT THIS POINT TO
OFFER SUPPORT WE THINK THAT
THERE IS A LOT GOOD ABOUT THIS
BILL. UP WE THINK THE CONCEPT IS
GOOD WE HAVE A FEW SPECIFIC
ISSUES AROUND. ARE OVER THE
COUNTER PHARMACEUTICALS THAT IF
THEY ARE NOT DEEMED TO BE USABLE
OR ABLE TO BE.
SENT TO SOMEPLACE THAT NEEDS
THEM THAT THEY MAY END UP IN NOT
IS HAZARDOUS WASTE BUT JUST
THROWN IN THE TRASH AND END UP
AN ARMBAR MAY.
THAT SAID WE ARE WORKING WITH
STAFF WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE IF PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL TO TRY TO WORK OUT
SOME OF THESE DETAILS SO WE'RE
HOPING TO COME TO A SUPPORT.
POSITION ARE NOT QUITE THERE YET
BUT.
GLAD TO BE WORKING WITH FOLKS.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NOW WITH THAT ON MEMBERS OF ANY
QUESTIONS.
SECURE WAS LIKE CLOSE.
YES JUST THAT I'LL BE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS HAVE WE HEARD
SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE
HEARD QUESTIONS ABOUT
DISCLOSURE.
AND ABOUT THE.
SPUR SMITH OF.
OF MEDICAL PRODUCTS
ARE THOSE ARE CERTAIN ALL THINGS
THAT I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE ON.
AND THIS ENJOYS A.
VOTE RECOMMENDATION OF I'VE IN
THE CHAIR.
WITH DONE AND SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY QUIRK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK
HI QUIRK.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA BY
BRO.
PEROT NOT FOUND.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
RIGHT TO CHEAT. WHAT'S RICHIE.
SIX.
WHAT WAS OUT?
YOU'RE.
ALL RIGHT.
WILL NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR FOR
RUNNING OF THE COMMITTEE.
.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE NOT
YET VOTED ON ALL THE ISSUES
WE'RE GOING TO.
GO THROUGH THEM AND GET THE
ADDITIONAL AT ADDITIONAL VOTES.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
PROCEED.
SO THIS IS I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR  WE HAVE A SIX TWO
ZERO VOTE COUNT AB BROKE.
THANK YOU SEVEN SO THAT'S AN ICE
SEVEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTY QUIRK.
I THE VOTE NOW IS FOUR ZERO
ADEMOLA. ARAMBULA AYE.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN MY
SELECT.
ITEM NUMBER CHIU A. B. TWO ZERO
SEVEN TWO.
QUIRK.
ARAMBULA.
HER NUMBER I.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
SO THAT'S SEVEN ZERO FINAL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS A BE TWENTY
NINETY FOUR KALRA.
THE VOTE STANDS AT FOUR TO ONE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING BRO.
IT BROKE NO NO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE ANDREAS.
THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
BRO.
BRO I
SEVEN SIR.
THANKS EVERYONE AND I WILL CALL
THE ME THE GUY HEARING CLOSED